[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
double transcriptomic reads in single
cell rna-seq using molecular depletion
i am marie stone of labyrinths and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by jump code genomics to learn more
visit
jumpcodegenobics.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
john besney research assistant associate
third
research and development at jump code
genomics
john you may now begin your presentation
hi everyone my name is john besney i'm a
research associate 3 here at jumco
genomics and today i'm going to tell you
about one of our products that enhances
the signal to noise in single cell
rna-seq the name of our product is
crispr clean
if you go on our website the actual name
of this product you'll see here on the
slide crisper clean single cell rna
boost kit
and like many of you guys know that are
familiar with single cell rna-seq while
it is incredibly useful at separating
out individual cells of different types
it does have its issues what i'm showing
you here on this slide are some of the
issues that is essentially confound our
downstream computational interpretation
one of those you'll see on the far left
panel is that of the total amount and
number of mrna that's inherent within a
cell the traditional single cell rna-seq
the 10x methods you only only capture
about 10 to 20 percent of those inherent
mrna
the second part this middle column is
that the data itself is incredibly
sparse this ends up being an issue for
some of our computational processing
downstream in terms of efficiency and
weeding out if a zero is an actual zero
or if a zero is a dropout aka the mrna
was there but was lost its at some point
during the experimentation process
and lastly on the right
that there's a high amount of noise and
what this paper what this graph is
showing you is that the counts per gene
of two cells of the exact same cell type
the r squared value is incredibly low
and you'll see things circled on the far
right like these massive number of
dropout events
essentially showing that taking averages
across means of cells is not necessarily
the best practice in interpreting single
cell rna-seq
in order to insert our crispr clean
workflow into the general
10x single cell rna-seq workflow what
you can see on the left is a description
of
our unwanted reads represented in purple
every we remove for the simple crisper
digestion
and as you can see we do this before the
pcr amplification in order to maximize
the number of unique molecules that are
recovered
you can see the workflow on the right
and the timeline incorporated
in total it takes about two hours from
start to finish but the hands-on time is
only 45 minutes
the outline of this presentation is
going to consist of the following
first i'm going to go over our proof of
concept essentially assess the initial
viability of this approach within
cardiovascular samples
second i'm going to talk about a
methodology for designing a robust
technology using a mass amount of
publicly available data and third
i'm going to show you the results of our
application on immune samples
now you guys might be thinking what are
we going to be removing within single
cell rna-seq data is there anything
useless that can be removed
and so to really set the scene what i'm
describing to you here is essentially a
schematic illustrating the reads that go
on the sequencer and the reads that get
used so in this graph on the green on
the bottom arrows the total number of
reads so 100 percent of these reads the
green reads are what goes on the
sequencer
after that about 90 percent or so
confidently aligned to the genome and
are actually used
now what you see on the top is this pink
bar represents that of those that align
confidently to the genome really only
about 50 percent 50 to 60 percent
aligned to the transcriptome and because
this is an rna-seq experiment so when
you do any of your alignment methods the
most canonical being using cell ranger
from the 10x platform
then you're really only taking those
that align to the transcriptome
and so thus you can see this top pink
box
highlighted in this pink dash line
represents that even if you have a
hundred percent of your reads that come
off the sequencer really only about 50
to 60 percent within the sample example
are really being used for downstream
processing
so what i'm showing you here is that
same schematic but overlaid on top
are the regions and the number of reads
that we target
for removal
so you can see here in this light blue
box
are the non-polyadenylated ribosomal rna
that again are totally removed from the
sequencing library are absolutely
ignored those account for about 10 of
the reads and thus we target for them
for removal
in addition you can see in the dark
purple box
about 100 of the top
highly expressed ribosomal and
mitochondrial genes
that are typically removed and do not
play an important part in identifying
unique cell types or cell phenotypes
those are also removed
and together they constitute about 36
percent of your reads
so in order to see if removing those
regions actually has any effect in
redistributing reads to lowly express
transcripts
and unique molecules and thus increasing
the signal to noise what i'm showing you
here is a schematic overview of the
initial experiment that we performed
there's a couple things here to note one
is that we are comparing the depletion
protocol in our crispr clean protocol to
running 10x as is the standard workflow
and this is incredibly important here
because it's essentially we've designed
this experiment to see
if our method is valuable above any
standard researcher performing the
method as is and the second important
thing to note is that
each comparison here while the schematic
isn't properly representing it but each
comparison here we're representing the
control
versus the depleted and those two
represent the same exact cells
so at the wta amplification step after
we have c dna we essentially split the
cdna equivalently
into two groups one being the control
and one being the crispr clean depletion
so essentially each of those groups
represents the same exact cells so
computationally at the end when we do
our comparison we're comparison
literally the same exact cells a cell to
cell basis comparison
and so lastly as you can see here based
off of the colors that one of the main
questions of this study is looking at
endothelial cells within coronary and
pulmonary
and essentially trying to answer the
question are there any unique
transcriptional differences between
coronary and pulmonary across these
samples
so if you focus on the graph on the left
the first cohort of samples are the
depleted crispr clean samples
and as you can see from the bar graph
you see this is the percent of reads
that essentially align to the
transcriptome and end up being used so
you can see right off the bat from these
base metrics we get about a 20 percent
boost in the amount of reads that are
used in downstream processing
now if you focus on the right you can
see at a sequencing depth
about twofold greater than the standard
sequencing depth about twenty five
thousand or thirty thousand reads per
cell
you can see the added value of
performing depletion we recover about a
250 more genes per cell we recover an
additional 2 000 unique molecules per
cell
and because of that what we see is about
an additional 800 or 900 genes that are
incorporated into downstream processing
and thus are biologically relevant
now what i didn't tell you about these
samples is that these are only
endothelial samples so they're really
predominantly only one main cell type
and the goal of this analysis is to
really dissect individual subtypes
within these this one main cell type
so what you can see here
represented in these u-map plots that in
both the standard and depleted there's
only really one cohort of cells with
many different subtypes that cohort
representing the again one main
endothelial type is represented in this
purple dash line
another thing that's fantastic to see is
that the depleted doesn't alter
the underlying transcriptional state of
these cells
represented here that the u maps are
almost a mirror image of each other
now what's very interesting and the
added value of depletion becomes
apparent once we begin looking a little
bit more closely at some of these
subtypes within these endothelial cells
so what i'm doing here is on the next
couple of slides i'm essentially picking
randomly some of these subtypes within
the main cohort of cells
and looking at the differentially
expressed gene relative to all other
subtypes within the sample and that's
being represented here within these
volcano plots
and you can see on the left in the
standard if you're looking at this as a
normal researcher you would look at this
volcano pawn and you would see cohorts
of genes both upregulated and down
regulated pass the log to full change of
two to four
so you would look at this and you would
say this is a massively different
subtype the g the cells represented in
this orange sample are wildly different
from the cells in its surrounding
neighborhood
now if you look on the depleted remember
we've added an additional close to 250
300 genes per cell but more importantly
we've added an additional 2 000 unique
molecules per cell these samples here
represent about 50 000 cells
and so by redistributing those reads to
lowly expressed and essentially reducing
the dropout and noise within the sample
what you can see here is
a greater biological interpretation that
represents the ground truth
the same number of genes are different
amongst the same exact cell type
the only differences is a massive
shrinking and those thresholds in those
log two full change so if you look at
this as a as a researcher now you don't
see those massive differences in genes
that you saw in the standard condition
this again like i said more accurately
represents the ground truth that this is
one main cell type and these are just
different nuanced subtypes within this
main group of endothelial cells
i'm showing you here a different subtype
within the group of endothelial cells
just to show that this is pervasive
across all subtypes it's not just one
subtype essentially by redistributing
these reads we do a fantastic job of
collapsing
the differences that were initially just
inherent noise within the data
you can imagine again that in the
standard condition
if we have genes that are only captured
by those cells simply because
they were dropped out in the sequencing
data within the other cells that they
essentially end up being interpreted as
phenotypic signal
by removing those and redistributing
reads more evenly across lowly expressed
and capturing more unique molecules we
can see a reduction in this technical
noise and we do a better job of
interpreting the biological data
now you might remember that one of the
main goals of this was to be able to
discern transcriptional differences
between coronary and pulmonary
now what you're seeing here are the
results of batch correction following
the same exact batch correction the same
exact computational methods on the left
when you have again batch correction
fifty percent of these cells are
coronary fifty percent of these cells
all are pulmonary what i'm highlighting
in the purple dashed lines
is that massive regions where the batch
correction essentially does an
incredibly poor job of overlaying cells
of these different different types and
one and creating one integrated manifold
interpretation
now you can see that on the right the
coronary and pulmonary essentially every
single colored subgroup within that
graph
is represented in both coronary and
pulmonary incredibly evenly it's almost
as if they're mirror images of each
other except for only that one region
that i've highlighted in purple down
below
again this intuitively makes sense these
are endothelial cells from blood vessels
the only difference so they're the exact
same cells the only difference is where
those blood vessels are located
so when we perform a differential
expression analysis between the coronary
and pulmonary cells what i'm showing you
here are the results of the top eight
genes that come out of that analysis so
the first four represented in the x-axis
on the top
are genes that are essentially up
regulated within coronary pulmonary
within coronary excuse me and then the
next four are the top four genes that
are down regulated in coronary relative
to pulmonary as you can see the same
genes are showing up from the analysis
so again we're not losing any of this
biological signal
but you can see if we wanted to pinpoint
which of these subgroups is really the
differentiating factor
lending to this difference between
coronary and pulmonary cells if you
focused on the heat matrix on the left
within the standard condition it would
be incredibly hard to pinpoint any one
of these subgroups as the main causal
factor kind of driving this difference
between coronary and pulmonary
but right by removing that technical
noise and adding an additional 2 000
unique molecules per cell across 50 000
cells
you can see it becomes incredibly clear
that there's really only one sub
subgroup that is driving this difference
between coronary and pulmonary
endothelial cells
now just to confirm that our findings
are on track with previously published
data sets in bulk analysis
what i'm showing you here is a network
diagram the gene set enrichment on the
left of that one subgroup and you can
see highlighted in purple
are the genes that are playing the most
significant part in these biological
processes
that you can see on the bottom right
things like blood
vessel morphogenesis
external encapsulating structure
organization and extracellular matrix
organization
now what's interesting is that all of
these genes have been previously
identified in bulk analysis
leading to the buildup of plaque within
coronary blood vessels
so this essentially shows that
while depletion increases this
biological interpretation that it's not
something incredibly nuanced that it
makes sense based off of previous
published data sets and bulk analysis
so we did a fantastic job of removing
about 36 percent of unwanted reads and
redistributing those leading to an
increase in about 2 000 unique molecules
per cell
but are there any other reads within our
data that can be removed that are
unnecessary to interpret any sort of
biology
so what i'm showing you here is the
exact same schematic that i showed at
the beginning
the light blue representing the
non-polyadenylated ribosomal reeds the
dark purple representing the
polyadenylated ribosomal and
mitochondrial reeds and now we're adding
two extra groups that we have targeted
for depletion
one represented in kind of this
turquoise right next to the ribosomal
rna reads is what's labeled as
unaligned reads and unaligned reads
essentially are these consensus
intervals across all sample types and
tissue types
that are these genomic intervals that
essentially show up across all of these
data sets perhaps they are poly a
stretches that get captured and
amplified during the rt generation
and second
represented in the light purple next to
the dark purple rib ribometal are these
non-variable genes and you can think of
these as highly expressed housekeeping
genes whose expression does not change
across cell types
so essentially if it doesn't change
across cell types then it plays no role
in interpreting and distinguishing
different cell types within single cell
rna-seq data and is perfect for removal
so what we did to ensure that this was a
robust group of genes in regions
targeted for removal we essentially
performed in silicon depletion of 14
publicly available single cell sra
datasets
so on the far left if we only remove the
non-polydenylated ribosomal rna that
represents about 10 percent of aligned
breeds
in dark purple if we only removed
the top expressed ribosomal and
mitochondrial genes represents about 30
percent of reads remember these data
points is across all 14 sample and
tissue types
if we combine those two together we get
up to about 42 percent
now if we add on in addition to those
guide sets if we add on
the guides targeting those unaligned
genomic intervals we can get up to about
50 of reeds that could be removed and
redistributed to lowly expressed rare
and unique molecules
and lastly if we add on those
non-variable genes the genes that aren't
playing any role in biological
interpretation we can get up to about 58
60 percent of our reeds that could be
removed and redistributed
so the schematic i'm showing you here is
the experimental overview
of what we performed combining all of
these guide sets within pbmc samples so
what we're showing you is on the far
left is that we're comparing our
depleted conditions that were performed
in triplicate against the control and
the control here again is just the
standard 10x workflow and same as before
each of these control versus depleted
condition
represents
wta splits of the exact same cell types
so right off the bat if we look at the
distribution of reads in the far left on
the control
you can see in green that represents not
informative transcriptional reads in
blue represents informative
transcriptional reads and in purple
represents the rest of the reeds that
align to the genome and thus aren't used
now on the right what you can see
is a almost twofold enhancement in that
blue region or in other words a 100
percent increase in the reads that map
to the transcriptome that are
informative
now if we dive in a little bit further
and look on a cell by cell basis you can
see on the far left a sequencing
saturation curve that is as we increase
in sequencing depth per cell we're
simply recovering more and more unique
molecules per cell
at the end of the day at a sequencing
depth of about 25 000 reads per cell
depletion recovers an additional 280
genes per cell
and about additional 500 unique
molecules per cell
and this correlates to an additional
2000 genes that contribute to biological
signal that otherwise would not have
been found within the control
now before i jump into some of the umap
plots
for those of you that are familiar with
the analysis of single cell rna-seq i
want to ensure everyone that i am not
and did not perform any manual
annotation of this data set
in order to
automatically identify the cell types
within pbmc databases
we leverage a tool that uses predefined
legacy markers so this is an automatic
annotation tool that essentially
references massive repositories of
single cell pbmc data
containing over a million cells
so when we use that tool on both data
sites
you can see here some of the canonical
cell types that show in with show up
within pbmc cells those included in the
far left like pink are showing up these
natural killer cells
and on the right those same natural
killer cells are now in the bottom right
corner identified in blue so you can see
we're we're recovering these same exact
sound types
with one
notable difference
on the left
kind of highlighted and circled in this
purple dash line
you can see that
the control is unable to distinguish
between the cd4 monocytes and these two
kind of arms that are branching out from
the cd-14 monocytes
whereas in the depleted condition you
can see one of those arms actually
separate within transcriptional space
and identify and distinguish between
cd14 and cd16 monocytes
in addition it also has the ability to
characterize these rare cell types of
dendritic cells cd1c positive dendritic
cells that represent less than one
percent of the cell population in
absolute frequency
just to confirm that the results
previously mentioned were not a factor
of the computational analysis or
automatic annotation tool
what we did is we performed this
unsupervised cell clustering that uses
deep learning to automatically identify
the proper number of clusters
represented within your data
using this tool what we found is that
depletion still recovers two additional
cell types using this unsupervised
clustering approach
on the far left you can see labeled the
control sample we find about nine
clusters
and the depleted sample we find about 11
clusters
you can see on the bottom left in the
control cluster number six the depletion
because of the redistribution of genes
and the additional 2000
genes that are playing a part in
biological interpretation cluster number
six is split into two individual
clusters
and lastly this kind of arm that
connects cluster one and cluster 0 in
the control is essentially totally
separated into its own cluster and you
can see there is no longer any sort of
connection between cluster 0 and cluster
1.
in addition to give us some confidence
in assuring that these two additional
clusters are actually real
this tool also assigns a probability of
those clusters being separate clusters
the probability you can see as a colored
heat matrix on the right of this graph
going from about
0.2 being yellow all the way up to 0.8.9
represented in dark blue dark purple
so you can see those two those
additional clusters in the bottom right
that were separated as well as those in
the top right in the depleted this tool
assigns a very high confidence a high
probability assuring us that these are
actually two different clusters
so what i've showed you up to this point
is that
we can sequence the same
and recover more information by
performing depletion
but
on the other end of that coin
can we sequence less perhaps half the
number of sequencing reads but recover
the same exact information using crispr
clean depletion
so what i'm showing you here are the raw
metrics within this table
this first column represents the control
or the non-depleted so at a sequencing
depth about 27 000 reads per cell you
can see the same number of cells in that
second row
but on the bottom two rows genes per
cell we recover about a thousand three
hundred genes per cell and about close
to two thousand unique molecules per
cell
now the second column represents if we
just took half the same exact sample and
sequence to half you can see here again
representing about thirteen thousand
five hundred reads per cell
we don't recover exactly half but we
recover significantly less genes per
cell in um is per cell in those bottom
two rows
now
if we take essentially that same exact
sample of cells
perform depletion and only sequence to
half you can see we recover
the number of genes per cell and the
number of unique molecules per cell
and on the right what i'm showing you is
a distribution of those reads and genes
per cell and um i counts per cell of the
depletion at half the sequencing depth
and the control at the full sequencing
depth you can see there is no bias in
the distribution of the data and almost
a perfect overlay of the counts per cell
and genes per cell
even more surprisingly now when we
compare the umap plots of the control at
27 000 reads per cell and they depleted
at half the sequencing depth in the
depleted condition we surprisingly still
recover the ability to identify those
two additional cell types that were
unable to be identified within the
control sample
so just to recap i would like to point
out that we recover an additional
essentially 100 percent boost in
informative reads within our pbmc
samples
we recover an additional about 1.5 fold
increase in genes per cell and unique
molecules recovered per cell
and this enables us to recover an
additional two
cell types within our pbmc sample data
that could not have been identified
otherwise
so all in all depletion increases the
sensitivity of single cell
experiments and allows one to recover
the same information
at half the number of sequencing reads
so in conclusion depletion recovers more
information per cell
we
increase the signal to noise by
performing depletion
and by redistributing those reads
depletion statistically enhances the
biological interpretation
i would like to thank the entire team
here at jumpcode genomics
as well as the pandey lab at scripps
research as well as the scripps genomics
score that helped with the sequencing
this was a team effort and could not
have been done alone and please let me
know if you have any questions
thank you john for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click on the ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started
our first question is does the crispr
clean reaction use all the c dna from my
10x prep
yes that's a great question so the
answer is no it doesn't so the
traditional 10x workflow
is after you generate the
oil droplets with your cells
go through and generate the cdna or the
wta is what they call it the whole
transcriptome amplification
at that point you come to a nice
stopping point
and
at that point what you can do is you can
quantify your cdna and you actually
split your cdna into four equivalent
groups even according to the protocol
so what you do here is in depletion is
you just take one of those splits
and perform the depletion on one of
those splits so if you want to compare
it
to a control like you saw at this
presentation with our two experiments
then you essentially only use two out of
the four splits one would be your
control your standard tenants processing
and then the other one would be for your
depletion go through the protocol
which also raises another excellent
point then i just want to reiterate is
that all the experiments that you had
seen because we're splitting it at the
cdna the controls are depleted represent
the same exact cells so the comparisons
here are incredibly robust as if you're
comparing if you had 10 000 cells it's
almost as if you're comparing every cell
against itself
okay
thank you
next question
does crispr clean depletion introduce
bias to my gene expression readout
no absolutely not so this is one of the
first things that we looked for
and so if you take
every gene in a control sample in every
gene
in a depleted sample and if you look at
simply the correlation or the r squared
value of all 15 or 17 000 genes that you
have
it would be incredibly close to one it's
all the samples you've seen are 0.98
0.99 so essentially round up to 1. so
the key here is that we're not changing
the distribution of the genes or
changing the relative expression we're
simply providing kind of more value for
what you would get where you take the
reeds that are typically
totally ignored and removed
computationally we're taking those
reasons redistributing them to lowly
express genes and unique molecules that
otherwise wouldn't be captured so we're
just increasing the sensitivity and
specificity without
distrib
biasing the gene expression
okay thank you
next question
where can i find detailed information on
this kit
yeah absolutely so if you go to jumpco
genomics.com
and you can browse through our website
there you will see some
very much detailed information about
some of the specifics
on this kit and if you remember at the
beginning of this as this presentation
look for
crispr clean
sc boost
and you'll be able to find more
information about the experiments that
we reviewed today some of the detailed
metrics as well as some of the
actual raw data if you want to peruse
through the data yourself
and kind of check out that we see this
added
boosts and unique molecules and genes
and you can also download the
information on our website as well
great
well it looks like we have time for one
more question is this kit compatible
with the five prime chromium assay what
about vision spatial
yeah so that's a great question
um so one of the reasons if you remember
about the middle of this presentation
that we did a deep dive into accessing
publicly available data as we wanted to
make a product that was not only
universal
really across different biological
samples and different replicates and as
well as different tissue types but we
wanted to make sure that the reads that
we are seeing were also found in other
kits and other assays
and so we have now done some preliminary
experiments within a five prime chromium
assay and it worked fantastic
as well as some preliminary experience
experiments within the vision spatial
and we see very similar effects where
we're able to remove these
unwanted unusable reads and redistribute
them to lowly express read so yes it
seems like this is pervasive across a
lot of platforms within 10x genomics
great thank you again john for your time
today and your important research
we would also like to thank labrutz and
our sponsor jump code genomics for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time goodbye
you